les élections municipales se tiendront
les dimanches 15 et 22 mars prochains à
la verrière s'est confirmée et nelly tu
sera bien candidate pour un nouveau
mandat la maire communiste sortante l'a
confirmé vendredi lors d'une réunion au
scarabée en présence des habitants elle
avait succédé pour appel à alain ajaj
démissionnaire en 2016 l'élu qui
souhaite pour cette campagne associé les
verrières voie à son projet une série
d'ateliers de concertation doivent se
tenir jusqu'à la fin novembre
tous les sujets locaux pour y être
abordés afin d'alimenter ensuite la
rédaction d'un programme pour le scrutin
écouter nelly du tube ses prix le mandat
en août je puis dire et on fera alors
j'ai mis un temps à devenir mère parce
que je crois que pourtant c'est pareil
un temps et puis là-bas les idées
commencent à venir les envies de faire
surtout surtout surtout participer les
habitants je crois que c'est le noeud de
beaucoup de
de résolution de problèmes d'un côté
mais aussi de solutions
je pense que c'est chez les gens on va
trouver les solutions pour avancer une
élite youtube qui ne ferme pas la porte
aux 13 élus dissidents de la majorité
qui ont créé en début d'année leur
propre groupe au sein du conseil et
municipales parmi lesquels 1 le maire
l'anssi